a melanin Bam Bam Bam it's ah hi Bob I'm
gonna be coming over to you I'm gonna
hop on the plane then go over here and
then probably here maybe here a little
bit here same thing under here been true
that and then I'm gonna land and visit
you at your own home because we're gonna
be doing a charity livestream together
for Muse aid and if you don't know about
music which you probably should
considering you told me Bob it's a
charity that supports musical
institutions in developing countries
it's great so I'm gonna bring my guitar
and I'm gonna bring my trunk pad and
we're gonna have ourselves duo baby
yeah I got axle trumpet here hang on ha
almost got it so all you people out
there watching please join us this
Saturday for a charity livestream of
epic proportions and you know what they
say Marga Blair doesn't know how to end
a video we're gonna jam out with our
kaca what